so we're told that quadrilateral ABCD is
the square which tells us that the four
sides have equal lengths and that they
are all the interior angles are 90
degrees we also know that FG FG is a
perpendicular bisector of BC so we've
already shown that it's perpendicular
that this is a 90 degree angle but it
also bisects BC so this length is equal
to that length right over there then
they tell us that arc AC that's a curve
on top arc AC is part of circle B so
this is a circle centered at B so this
is the center of the circle this is part
of part of that circle it's really kind
of the bottom left quarter of that
circle and then given that information
they want us to find what the measure of
angle B edie is so what is B e D so it's
B II D so we need to figure out the
measure of this angle right over here
and I encourage you to pause it and try
it out and you might imagine well I you
could pause it and try it without any
hints and now I will give you a hint if
you if you tried it the first time and
you weren't able to do it and you should
pause again after this hint is try to
draw some triangles that maybe split up
this angle into a couple of different
angles and it might be a little bit
easier you might be able to use some of
what we know about triangles now with
that said I will try to solve it and you
should pause at any point where you
think that you know exactly how to do
this and try to do it yourself so the
trick here is to realize that this is a
circle and so any any line that goes
between B and any point on this arc is
going to be equal to the radius of the
circle so a B is equal to the radius of
circle B E is equal to the radius of the
circle and we can keep drawing other
things that are equal to the radius of a
circle B C is equal to the radius of the
circle so let's think about a little bit
if we were to draw in a lot of trickier
geometry problems really all revolve
around drawing the right lines or
visualizing the right triangles and I'll
do one right here that might open up a
lot for you in terms of hot thinking
about how to do this problem so let me
draw a segment EC and draw that as
straight as possible
I can draw a better job of that
so segment EC now something becomes
interesting because what is what is the
relationship between triangle EBG and
triangle ECG well they both definitely
share they both share this side right
over here they both share side EG and
then B G is equal to G C and they both
have 90 degree angles you have a 90
degree angle here you have a 90 degree
angle there so you see by side angle
side side angle side that these two
triangles are going to be congruent so
we know that triangle triangle e b G is
congruent to triangle ECG II CG I should
emphasize the C not the e ECG buy
side-angle-side congruence by
side-angle-side congruence and that also
tells us that all of the corresponding
angles and sides are going to be the
same so that tells us that tells us
right there that EC that EC is equal to
EB EC is equal to EB so we know that EB
EB is equal to EC and what is what also
is equal to that length well once again
this is the radius of the circle ve is 1
radius of the circle going from the
centre to the arc but so is BC it is
also radius of the circle going from the
centre to the arc so this is also equal
to this is also equal to BC so I could
draw this other other three things right
here I'm referring to the entire thing
not just one of the segments all of BC
so what is what kind of a triangle is
this right over here triangle B EC
triangle B e C is equilateral
equilateral and we know that because all
three sides are equal so that tells us
that all of its angles are equal so that
tells us that the measure of angle B EC
VEC we're not done yet
but it gets us close is 60 degrees so
the measure of angle B EC right over
there
sixty degrees so that gives us part of
the problem B EC is part of the angle B
e D if we can just figure out the
measure of angle CED now if we can
figure out this angle right over here we
just add that to sixty degrees and we're
done we figured out the entire the
entire be e d now let's think about how
we can do this right over here so
there's a couple of interesting things
that we already do know we know that
this right over here is equal to the
radius of the circle and we also know
that this length down here this is a
square we know that this length down
here is the same as this length up here
that these are the exact same length and
this is equal to the radius of the
circle we already put these three
slashes here BC is the same as that
length is the same as that length and so
all four all four sides are going to be
that same length because this is a
square so let me write it let me write
this down because because it's a square
I'll just write it this way because it's
a square we know that we know that CD is
equal to BC which is equal to and we
already establishes is equal to C EC
which is equal to EB which is equal to
EC but the important thing here is to
realize that this and this are the same
length and the reason why that is
interesting is it lets us know that this
is an isosceles triangle it's an
isosceles triangle so whatever isosceles
triangle if you have your two legs of it
the two base angles are going to be
congruent so whatever angle this green
angle is this angle is going to be as
well so somehow somehow we can figure
out this angle right over here we can
subtract that from 180 and then divide
by two to figure out these two because
we know that they're the same so how can
we figure out this angle well we know
all the angles of this thing we can
figure out the angles of all of this
larger one up here we know this is
equilateral triangle so this over here
has to be 60 degrees as well that's 60
degrees and that is also 60 degrees in
fact I could write over here which is
equal to the measure of angle BCE
measure of
angle b.c.e
BCE so this is 60 degrees we know we're
dealing with the square so this whole
angle over here so is a right angle what
is the measure of angle ECD what is this
angle right over here let me do this in
a new color this right over here is
going to have to be 30 degrees so that
is going to be 30 degrees and now we're
ready to solve if you know now we're
ready to solve for these two base angles
if we call these X if you call these X
and we know they have to be the same we
have X plus X plus 30 degrees X plus X
plus 30 degrees is going to be equal to
180 degrees that's the sum of all of the
interior angles of a triangle so you get
2x 2x plus 30 plus 30 is equal to 180
degrees now you can subtract 30 from
both sides and we are left with 2x is
equal to 150 divide both sides by 2 you
get X is equal to 75 so we figured out
that X is equal to 75 and now we're at
the home stretch we need to figure out
angle B edie well that's going to be
angle C so X is equal to the measure of
angle CED so ve D is CED plus CED plus B
EC so the 60 degrees plus 75 degrees so
it's going to be ready for the drum roll
this is going to be equal to 75 degrees
plus 60 degrees which is equal to 135
degrees and we are done